ALEXEY KOKIN: My name is Alexey.
I'm with Google Play Business
Development for Application
in Central and Eastern Europe.
RICCARDO GOVONI: And I'm
Riccardo, Engineering Lead
on Android Vitals.
ALEXEY KOKIN: And
we are going to talk
with you about application
quality in Android.
Application quality
in Android has always
been a top priority for us.
And we have been moving
away from just installations
and user rights in Play
application and start
focusing on more complex
and exact metrics,
like engagement and
[INAUDIBLE] performance.
Today, we are going to talk
about this all in detail.
First of all, why it's
important to have a quality app.
Then, how can you troubleshoot
your technical issues
and master Android vitals?
And how you can build
an excellent product
on this great
technical foundation.
First of all, why
quality matters.
Why it's important?
Quality directly
impacts the success
of your business on Google Play.
We have run an analysis
on our top apps and games
in Google Play ranking
their quality score.
And we have seen some
spectacular results.
For example, when application
moved from average
to good quality, we can
see up to seven time uplift
in retention and six time uplift
in spend in those applications.
Our partners support
those findings.
For example, Zalando, Europe's
leading fashion platform,
they focused on reliability
and performance,
eliminating bugs and making
their application faster.
And this has not only
increased the organic traffic
they're getting.
It provided the positive
impact on their revenue growth
in the LTV lifetime
value per user.
How much stability matters?
The answer is it matters a lot.
Again, our findings found out
that if the application crashes
a lot-- and "a lot" means
more than 5% crashes,
they have a 30% more
uninstallation in the first day
than more stable apps.
You have seen this previously.
But again, I want to remind you
that application performance
and quality is the main
driver of your user rankings.
60% of negative reviews
mention stability and crash.
And 60% of positive reviews
mentioning speed, design,
and reliability.
You know what to focus on
to make your app excellent.
Again, our partners
support those findings.
Busuu, a language learning app,
they saw significant growth
in their average ranking when
they increase the performance
of the applications.
And everybody
knows how difficult
it is to grow the application
from already higher ranking
for 4.1.
Lastly, in addition to
those objective reactions
and your business goals,
there are some rewards
you can get from
Google Play from having
quality applications.
Those benefits are the
boost of organic traffic,
featuring, and some occasional
awards you can get from us.
For example, if the
application crashes a lot,
it gets a lot of negative
reviews and bad user ratings.
it can decrease your application
promotability in Google Play.
And when there's picking an
application for featuring,
we have already paid
a lot of attention
to its overall quality
and platform support.
Now, we are starting to
look at your Android vitals
to see if the apps actually
performs and works stable.
And at the end of the
day, you can get a lot
of specific Google awards.
We sometime run some
kind of best application
of the year or
material design award,
which can do wonders for your
PR and promote your application.
One such award is
Android Excellence,
which we have announced
on Google I/O,
and which we have updated
two times already.
It's a quarterly collection
of our best content, best apps
and games the Android
system has to offer.
And this is some top
and great applications
you can look for inspiration
and some great ideas
on how to build
Android applications.
Now, to the
technical excellence.
RICCARDO GOVONI: Thank you.
So you heard from Kobe in the
keynote about Android Vitals.
I want to spend 10
minutes walking you
through how it can help you.
What is Android Vitals?
Android Vitals is a
program that Google
create to help you create apps
and games of exemplary quality.
We launched it at Google I/O
with Android Vitals dashboard
in the Play Console.
In there, you can see aggregated
performance information
about your app.
Data is collected
automatically, no action
required from you, from
millions of devices worldwide,
from any user that has agreed
to share data with Google.
For example, when they
unbox their new device.
Thanks to this, everyone
in your companies,
from engineers all
the way to the CEO,
can understand app quality
and set KPIs around it.
How does Android Vitals work?
It's a combination
of three things--
metrics, tools, and rewards.
Metrics.
I mean, bad behaviors.
These are application practices
and patterns and events
that are detrimental
to the user experience,
like crashes and battery
drains, all the things
that you want to avoid.
Tools in Play Console to help
you understand and improve
your app quality
from before release
with the pre-launch report,
at release time with Release
Dashboard, and
after release when
your app is live with the
Android Vitals Dashboard.
And finally, rewards.
As Alexey mentioned, rewards in
search and discovery for apps
that show exemplary behavior.
What I mean by "bad behaviors?"
If you go to Android
Vitals today,
so far you will see that
we explain performance
across three key domains--
stability, battery,
and rendering.
For stability, we tell you
whenever your application
is crushing or freezing.
Application not responding.
For battery, we
already inform you
when your application is causing
unnecessary battery drains.
For example, by keeping
the CPU on excessively
or for too long amount of time,
or waking the device up too
often.
And for rendering, we highlight
whenever the application
is slow, slower than
60 frame per second,
or stuttering with
frozen frames.
We've seen massive
momentum since we launched
at Google I/O. Over 65% of
Play top apps are engaging
with Android Vitals
regularly, over 60,000 app
developers worldwide.
And by working closely with
over 50 partners, some of you
in the audience as
well, we observed
that they were able, on
average, to reduce their crash
rate from 3.5% down to
1.7%, which is massive.
And this means that
since Google I/O,
over 1.5 billion installations
were delivered to users,
leading them to apps that
are better and less crashing.
Thanks to these,
for many partners,
Android Vitals is now an
active part of their planning.
And they observe a direct
impact on customer satisfaction
by focusing on app quality,
like the Weather Channel here.
So inspired by all
of this, I want
to announce three
new things today--
expanded device coverage,
five additional new metrics
to help you understand
and act on app
quality, and a completely
new user experience
in the Play Console.
First, expanded device coverage.
Until now, Android Vitals only
reported performance pertaining
to Nexus and Pixel devices.
In the last three months,
we worked with several OEMs
to surface performance
metrics for many new devices,
across the spectrum from
high-end flagship devices,
to mid-range bestsellers,
to low-end devices.
And this means that
we are able to cover
over 50 times more
amount of sessions
tracked by the program.
So if until now you
were not able to get
sufficient representative
information in Android Vitals,
I encourage you to
go and check it today
because it's going
to be much better.
We increased the set of
metrics that we report,
starting with additional metrics
around stability and battery.
For stability, obviously,
repeating crashes
induce user frustration
because the apps
appears irremediably broken and
this leads to high uninstalls.
So now you can see
additional new metrics
around multi-ANRs,
percentage of sessions
during which users experience
more than one freeze
during a session.
And the same for crashes.
On battery, we focused on
excessive background activity.
Excessive background activity
consumes unnecessary battery
when the user is
away from the phone.
And your app will not receive
much usage if the phone is dead
when the user comes back to it.
And so we have three
new metrics there.
One is excessive Wi-Fi
scans in the background.
Whenever the apps
perform too many
Wi-Fi scans when
not in active use.
Same is for excessive
network usage.
You will be able to see whenever
your application is consuming
an excessive amount of
data and network usage
while the app is not in active
use, and stuck background wake
locks, the percentage
of sessions
when the app was keeping the
CPU on for more than one hour
while it was in the
background, not in active use.
To help you with
all of this, we also
significantly revamped the
Play Console user experience
to help you understand,
improve your app
quality in easier ways.
There is a new
Overview page that
helps you understand
your overall app
quality at a glance across
all performance metrics.
This is live now.
You can go and
check it out as soon
as you're out of this session.
There is a new--
straight at the top of the
page in the highlighted section
that points out
any bad behaviors
that are triggering
for your app right now.
So you can immediately focus
on the most important actions.
You can now track the
performance of your app
over time and see
whenever you improve
or you regress on your
application quality.
And observe the
impact of the actions
that you took to improve.
To facilitate recursion
for any bad behaviors that
might trigger, your
can now slice the data
by any combination of version
code, devices, OS version,
time, to really dive into,
what are the main problems that
may be affecting your app?
And to help you understand
the opportunity even further,
you have now benchmarks that
help your establish reference
points.
How your behavior fares
against the top 10,000 apps.
And we highlight what
is the performance
of the bottom
quartile, so you can
see what the opportunity
for improvement
is for your app to
capture compared to peers.
And finally, we want to
help you take action and be
guided into recovery
whenever there is a problem.
So for example, in the case
of application freezes, which
are sometimes hard to debug
because multiple causes
contribute to them, we
now highlight what cause
led to them across
many different reasons,
from deadlocks, to excessive
disk I/O, to excessive network
I/O, excessive database
usage, suspended triads
due to garbage collection,
and much more, straight
from the Play Console UI.
So thanks to these, partners
are using Vitals more and more
to continue investing
in app quality.
And it's great to see feedback
like these from Big Fish
Games around specific features
like the effectiveness
of benchmarks.
I want to cover one more thing
around pre-launch report.
Pre-launch report
is Play solution
for automated app testing
before production releases.
It automatically crawls APKs
on 10 physical devices looking
for crashes and security
vulnerabilities.
And what we observe is that,
in 90% of the time, whenever
pre-launch report
discovers a crash,
the app was then not
pushed to production.
So very effective
in preventing bad
experiences reaching your users.
Three big news for these today.
First, no more need to
opt-in into the service.
This was the case until now.
Every APK that is going
to be now from today
submitted to alpha
or to beta track
will automatically be
tested by pre-launch report.
So for many of you, you will
now start seeing the results
without any opt-in to do.
We completely
rewrote and improved
the automated crawler
that navigates your app
to understand better
the content of your app
and reach deeper into that
with increased coverage
and be more effective
at detecting
crashes that would
have otherwise reached
users in production.
And the last one, we launched
an entire new section
centered on performance
metrics that
are collected during the crawl.
So as the robot
explores your app,
you will now then be able to
replay what the crawler did.
And next to the video
for what the crawler did,
you will see performance metric
around CPU, memory, network,
and rendering.
So you can understand if
specific actions in your app
are particularly troublesome.
All of these, I hope,
will help you leading you
to a healthy app.
But then, how do you
make it memorable?
And how do you
make it excellent?
And for this, I will
lead back to Alexey.
ALEXEY KOKIN: OK.
So Android Vitals,
hopefully, has
helped you to build
a great application
from the technical perspective.
It works stable.
It works fast.
It works smooth.
And there is no issues.
How do you go up from that?
And how do you build
an excellent product?
What is the next step?
The next step is
building useful products
from our useful
features the users love,
from using beautiful design and
using all Android platform can
offer you.
Let's talk about this in
a little bit more detail.
First of all, material design.
As a concept, got
a lot of praise
from independent developers
and independent designers.
There are a lot
of material about,
how can you implement
and adopt material
design in your
applications, most
from Google and
from our partners.
Remember that just [INAUDIBLE]
pre-made components.
We have plenty of them.
It does not make your
application material.
You should think material
and design your application
from the ground up, keeping
the main concept in mind.
And having you up in
material design definitely
helps your engagement.
Because users on
Android, they are
used to the common approaches
and common elements of material
design.
Next step is the
platform support.
A quality app is an
up-to-date application.
We encourage you to
use the latest SDK
and support the latest version
of Android operating system.
And as soon as there
is a new developer
preview of a next
version, or as soon
as there's a better
version of next Android
build, try and test your
application against it
to be ready for its release.
Of course, there are a
lot of different platforms
we've actually built on
Android and supporting
them will improve your
application quality.
And there are some
cross-platform tools,
for example, like sign in with
Google and Smart Lock which
help your users to create their
accounts or log in seamlessly.
Speaking about the
relevant platforms,
there are plenty of devices
running Android out there.
Wearable, tablets, smart TVs,
VR devices, and connected cars.
Not everything is relevant for
each your application's user
case.
But when it's
relevant, it definitely
help boost your
application quality
and benefit from
supporting those platforms.
Monetization with
Google Play billing
is another great example
of how your application can
increase the quality.
If the users love
your app so much,
they're ready to pay for your
content and for your services,
it's definitely a sign
of a quality application.
Either premium content, in-app
purchases, or subscriptions.
After you go through
a certain threshold,
we will consider
your application
as a more quality app.
Of course, there is
also Android Pay,
which is launched in many
regions across Europe.
Not Germany, of course.
But for example, in
Poland and Russia,
Android Pay is up and running.
And our partner reports
that they can get up to 20%
more playing users for their
services with Android Pay.
So support it and enjoy
additional revenue
and additional users.
Moving on from the application
itself to the Play listing.
This is the most important
thing for your organic traffic
and conversion to install.
There are a lot of
Play distinct tools,
which of course,
most of you already
knew and use, which include
promo videos, A/B testing,
and [INAUDIBLE] which help you
deliver quality applications
to your users.
You can also use
the Play Console
to respond to user reviews
in their native tongue,
helping resolve their issues and
boost your application rating,
keeping it about 4.
When your rating
is about 4 points,
it generally is
the main threshold
we need to put your app in some
kind of promos featuring them
as activities.
And of course, all
of those experiments
with the play listing help
with your conversions.
And our partners definitely
support those findings.
So if you experiment
with your screenshot,
with your description and
other parts of your listing,
it can boost your conversion.
For example, Wallapop, they
increased the conversion by 17%
by testing short
descriptions [INAUDIBLE]
and the screenshot orders.
For the best results
of such testing,
you definitely should
have a clear hypothesis
and some big design variations,
because only those activities
help you get variable,
great results.
So to sum everything up.
First of all, your
application quality
directly affects your
business success and customer
satisfaction.
RICCARDO GOVONI: And then, as I
mentioned with Android Vitals,
you can understand
and troubleshoot
your technical issues to lead to
an excellent app, from expanded
device coverage, new metrics,
new console experience,
an entirely revamped performance
section in pre-launch report,
and a better crawler.
ALEXEY KOKIN: And platform
adoption and product excellence
help can get more
traffic and become
more visible on Google
Play, getting more users
and helping your business grow.